it was a crazy night full of controversy
and chaos yes indeed and so much went
wrong technically but
the golden globes did get some things
right well there was diversity among
the winners yes there definitely was
including the most emotional win of the
night
for the late chadwick boseman
he would thank god he would thank his
parents
he would say something beautiful
something that would
amplify that little voice inside of all
of us that tells you you can
and i don't have his words
yet she did chadwick's wife simone
leeward boseman sat
poised strong and through tears accepted
his posthumous best performance in a
drama award
for ma rainey's black bottom we have to
take all the moments to celebrate those
we love
co-star viola davis did her best to
maintain composure while watching the
speech
and on instagram wrote simone was
perfect i spoke exclusively with her
about his nomination leading up to the
show
chadwick bozeman deserves it
i'm happy to be in any conversation with
him
even if it's the tagline
chadwick's black panther queen mother
and golden globe presenter angela
bassett told me
his award was going to be the highlight
of her night my heart
my son chadwick is up for an award so
looking forward to
you know to um to just seeing his face
pop
up on the screen there how are you
feeling today mama
it's nice to remember and recall his
brilliance and his spirit
chadwick and simone married in the
months before his tragic passing last
august from colon cancer
he rarely spoke about their five-year
relationship
simone you're with me every day love you
but with chadwick a critical
front-runner and several award shows yet
to take place
something tells us we will be hearing
from simone again
[Music]
you keep them coming
you